they say time heals off and while i
generally believe that saying
it's challenging to do so given these
unfavorable set of circumstances
before i conclude i must highlight a few
things
george's murder this trial and
everything in between
has been tragic and devastating our
family is forever broken
and one thing we cannot give back is
george floyd
it is the request of my family that the
maximal penalty
for the crime for which the defendant
was convicted to be imposed
on behalf of my family friends community
and supporters
i wish to express my sincerest gratitude
for allowing us opportunities
of expression thank you thank you sir
your honor first just for the record
this wonderful lady's family here
is a hennepin county victim uh advocate
um and uh
and so johanna will next uh hear from
the brother of george floyd uh
mr terence floyd
and mr floyd if you could state your
full name spelling each of your names
yes terence floyd
e s-t-e-r-r-e-n c e floyd floyd
go ahead
representing my brother i'm from new
york
on may 25th 2020
my brother was murdered everyone knows
by derek children the facts
of this case were proven beyond a
reasonable doubt
and three guilty verdicts would have
been rendered
the situation has really affected me
and my family
any family member that has went through
this
we are part of a fraternity of families
and it's not it's not one of those
you know fraternities that you enjoy
i just over this last year
and and once
i actually talked to a few people
and um
i wanted to know from the man himself
why
what were you thinking what was going
through your head
when you had your knee on my brother's
neck
why why when you when you knew that he
posed no threat anymore yeah he was
handcuffed
why you didn't at least get up why you
stayed there
[Music]
a month before my brother was
murdered i was on the phone with him
and we had a long conversation
and as i looked it i looked at the video
of my niece
the last conversation me and my brother
had was
he wanted to have play dates he wanted
to plan play dates with
gianna and my daughter and we
started setting it up
that can't happen and i have to
my daughter's still young but i still
have to
explain to her because this is history
this
this is the case everybody knows about
so she's gonna find out and i'm gonna
have to explain that to her
and i i think that's
to me harder than even just standing
here but i have to talk to my daughter
and tell her you know about her niece
about her uncle
about the situation that's basically
reliving it all over again
years down the line
i'm here on behalf of my friend me on me
i'm sorry
on behalf of me and my family we seek
the massive maximum penalty
we we don't want to see no more slaps on
the wrists
we've been through that already and
my community and my culture we've been
through that already
smacked on the wrist no no no no no
because if it was
us if it was the rose was reversed there
wouldn't be no case
it would have been open and shut we'd
have been under the jail
for murdering somebody
so we asked for that same penalty
for derek shoving thank you
thank you sir
you're on a final victim impact
statement for the state will come from
george floyd's
brother alanis floyd
answer you can begin by giving us your
full name
and spell each of your names and i have
permitted you to use your phone because
you have notes on it is that correct
yes sir all right and you may proceed
when you're ready
giving us your full name first
fallon is floyd spell p h
i l i-l-o-n-i-s-e
last name floyd floyd yeah
one year ago may 25th
my brother george was murdered by derek
sheldon
and his co-defendants in broad daylight
with a knee to his neck for nine minutes
and 29 seconds
i was a trucker and immediately my life
changed forever
i began to speak to the world for george
from the united nations
africa canada japan and so many other
countries
every day i have begged for justice to
be served
reliving the execution of george while
others
begged and pleaded for officer chauvin
to simply
just allow george to take a breath
i haven't had a real night's sleep
because of the nightmares i constantly
have hearing my brother big
and plead for his life over and over
again
even saying they're going to kill me
please
officer screaming for our mom
i i have had to sit through each day
of officer derek stoker's trial and
watch the video
of george dying for hours over and over
again
for an entire year i had to relive
george being tortured to death
every hour of the day only taking naps
and not knowing what a good night's
sleep is anymore
i've been lifting my voice tirelessly
every day
so that george's death will not be in
vain
honorable judge peter cahill i thank you
for allowing me to share this today
george's life mattered so my family and
i
most of all my niece gianna
my niece gianna she needs closure
i'm asking that you please find it
suitable to give officer shogun
the maximum sentence possible charge
that he has been found guilty for
my family and i have been given a life
sentence
we would never be able to get george
back
daddy's our daughter's first love
he would never be able to walk gianna
down allen held with him
attend those magical moments of her life
like a daddy daughter dance
sweet 16 party seeing her out for prom
graduations
and she will never be able to have any
personal memories with her father
with a smirk on his face insured in
prison
officer shogun used excessive force and
acted against his training
chauvin had no regards for human life
georgia's life i stand before you today
asking you to please help us find
closure
by giving children the maximum sentence
possible
making sure he does his time
perspectively
without the possibilities of parole
probation
or getting out early for good behavior
thank you
thank you sir
thank you
here today of course for sentencing
gives us an opportunity to speak about
um you know other matters that i think
are involved in sentencing and where we
are in the criminal justice system
in the processing of this case
as a as a member of an elected office
representing the people of the state of
minnesota
as well as people of the local community
i want to say a couple of things and
first of all i want to really thank
some of the police officers at the
minneapolis police department
who under great pressure
great stress to some extent compared to
their
their occupations um what they've
devoted their life to stuck to their
oath
and their commitment as police officers
to speak openly and honestly
about policing and the training
that is given and received by police
officers
those officers didn't hide behind a blue
wall
they came forward they told this court
and those jurors
what they knew about training and
responsibility
and i think they deserve recognition and
credit for that
i would also like to thank members of
the bureau of criminal apprehension
you know those agents get called in a
great sacrifice to their personal lives
whenever
things happen they don't they did that
here
and under really extraordinary
circumstances
completed a very professional and
thorough investigation
know conducting interviews is hard
enough but conducting them in the
atmosphere of the city
following the murder of george floyd was
even more difficult
and they did so i think above and beyond
the call of duty
and i want to thank them for doing that
on behalf of the whole prosecution staff
you know i want to thank the family the
loved ones
the friends of george floyd
they have been through so much more than
families involved in murder cases right
it is a it is a it's a fraternity you
don't want to be part
they've been through so much more
because of the pandemic
and because of security safety
precautions that we've had to take
they have been through a lot
at a time when they try to grieve like
everybody does the loss of someone
they are going through so much more and
i want to thank them
all of them the family the court saw
testimony from polonius floyd
courtney ross the other people are
trying to deal with their laws
but they have to do in a very public way
and under very trying circumstances
through no fault of their own so i thank
them they have all been
models of grace and
understanding and uh it's really
remarkable quite frankly
i'll uh i think come back to them again
in a little bit
your honor we have submitted a
sentencing brief um i
would incorporate that i guess i would
incorporate my comments to the end of
that memo
but i do think there are things that i
want to
bring out today in my arguments
for hundreds of years the court had
discretion in sentencing
it was the child court's decision what a
sentence should be
a recognition that the trial court sat
through the trial
watched the evidence and saw how it
affected people
informed the court's discretion when the
legislature passed the guidelines
in a legitimate attempt to try and even
out
sentences um they defined
certain presumptive sentences as we all
know for
typical crimes for each crime the
typical crime
but they did not remove discretion for
sentencing judges
they recognized that nobody is better
suited to decide whether this is the
typical case represented by that
guidelines presumptive sentence
or if there are reasons why this is
worse than that
and it gave and the guideline still
gives this court discretion
when there are aggravating factors to
give a more serious sentence than what
the guidelines presumption
calls for and as you know we are asking
you to do that
today
as this court found there are four
aggravating factors that we have
identified that go beyond a list of just
what those factors are
we have not just done our homework and
found a list
the court made good findings detailed
findings about those factors
and we think they justify uh a
greatly increased sentence this is not
the typical second degree
unintentional murder supreme court
in our state has said that and very
recently even one aggravating factor
is sufficient to go twice the top of the
range
here we have four
first one that the court found is an
abusive position of trust
and authority and the court specifically
found that
when mr chauvin was acting as a police
officer he had a position of trust and
authority
that is certainly true we trust police
officers
we trust them when we need help we call
them for help
we trust that they're going to take care
of the problems
that they are assigned to deal with
right we trust them
we also give them great authority we
give them great power
we give them power to use force that
individuals
would be prosecuted for using right we
give them
authority to um
arrest to detain
and with great power of course comes
great responsibility so they're not sent
out there by themselves to do this
they're given
substantial training this courts solo
all of that
through the trial in general and in
specific
to mr chauvin and the other three
officers they're given
training on the use of force the
proportional use of force the force used
has to be warranted by
the threat
they're given training on de-escalation
because we recognize
that police officers are called in when
people are not
having their best day when people might
be affected by
mental illness drug abuse uh any number
of issues they're just having
a bad day and they're trained for that
and should be
and they're taught how to use that to
de-escalate
and control a situation
they're taught medical intervention
they're taught to provide medical
attention to people who need it
being a police officer is a difficult
job we ask a lot of them
it's a profession there's no doubt about
it but we give them a substantial amount
of training
and most officers do it right this case
wasn't
about police officers
all police officers it wasn't about
policing this case was about
derek sheldon disregarding all that
training he received
and assaulting mr floyd until he
suffocated death
one of the things that you heard your
honor and the jurors heard
uh that can really encapsulate i think a
big
a very important issue here seven words
in your custody
it's in your care and
it's a real simple mantra it's a real
easy thing to remember
you're going to take custody of somebody
you have to provide care
you have to do it in a caring way you
can't simply disregard their care
mr chauvin abused his position of trust
and authority as a police officer
by doing just that disregarding hall's
training
it was an abuse of that because
what did he decide to do we often are
forced in this
you know criminal justice system to
infer people's state of mind by their
conduct and their statements
what was derek shovin's end game here
what was the plan
seems apparent the plan was hold them
down and
we can dump them in an ambulance and no
longer have them be our problem
you recall he said to charles mcmillan
he's a big guy
might be on something that's it
he held mr floyd down as mr floyd begged
for his life
he had the other officer's help in that
regard
and rather than doing the simple
experience of putting him on his side
he said yeah he was dismissive
to that duty of care
the typical second degree murder does
not include does not involve
that extent of abuse of a
deeply held position of abuse
or a position of authority and trust by
the community
by individuals of the community
your honor found that mr floyd was
treated by
or with by mr showman with particular
cruelty
i think
we know that
i mean we've all seen it mr floyd did
not want to be in the back seat
that's it and that's the that's the rub
it was the need to get him in that
backseat no matter what
and we all saw that once he was pulled
out of that backseat
he calmed right down even willingly went
down to the ground
i'm going down he said he went down to
the ground
not fighting not punching
and he was placed initially on his side
he's already handcuffed he's placed on
his side in the recovery position
like he should be because he's trying to
breathe
and then quickly placed prone on the
ground face down
mr chauvin put his left knee on george
floyd's neck
his right knee on george floyd's back
face down on the pavement
had officer king sit on
mr floyd's waist area and head officer
lane
hold his feet down you can even see mr
floyd trying to pull his feet up
we all are going to fight to breathe
everybody knows
that fear when you all of a sudden
realize you're having trouble breathing
it's just innate
right we want to survive we know we have
to breathe and there's an
automatic reaction when you begin to
feel like that
is threatened and you can see mr floyd
going through that
he tries to pull his feet up but he's
held down by these three officers while
officer tau is looking out
later of course goes to keep the people
who want to help away
he's placed face down in his pavement
so harshly that it rubs the skin off his
face
he has injuries to his face from being
faced on a pavement
he has injuries to his knuckles from
just trying to to lift himself up
and he's telling officer sheldon
i can't breathe i'm dying
and mr chauvin's response was uh-huh
and all this time i mean imagine what mr
floyd is going through we're going to
talk about particular cruelty and
torture really try to appreciate what
he's going through
he knows he's suffocating we all know
that
feeling of not being able to breathe
enough he's begging his pleading
and he's being ignored his concerns are
being dismissed by somebody who has
taken
custody but not care
he was kept in that prone position for
nine and a half minutes
and was suffocated there's no other way
to say it
that's particularly cruel that is more
cruel
than a typical second degree
unintentional murder
significantly more this is not a
momentary gunshot
punch to the face
this is nine and a half minutes
of cruelty to a man who was helpless
and just begging for his life
this court found that there were
children present
standing only a few feet from these
officers
these children who were ages 17
and one child aged 9.
why is that an aggravating factor well i
think everybody can
figure that out right it's particularly
bad
to commit a crime in front of children
we've heard a lot of
academia about you know the development
of the young brain and how long it can
take
and here you got a couple of teenage
girls and nine-year-old girl
how are they gonna process this you know
standing feet from
a man being suffocated by police
officers such a
stark sight that one of the children
even says we gotta call the police and
the police
how do you process that as a
nine-year-old
the children were not only present
watching a man die
we've all seen if you haven't you really
need to
look at george floyd's face because he's
dying he's suffering
the children have to watch this but not
only that
police officers and there are people
around them wanting to help
and at one point and sure they got upset
at one point mr chauvin points his mace
grabs his mace to keep him back
how's the child look at that there's
another officer screaming at them to get
back
the typical second-degree unintentional
murder doesn't involve
children standing feet away
watching a nine and a half minute
suffocation
of a man begging for his life
this court also made a finding that the
defendant committed the offense with the
involvement of three or more other
persons
lane and king were involved directly in
the restraint
and that tao
[Music]
kept the bystanders at bay
i've already talked a little bit about
lane and king's role in holding mr floyd
down
they recognized that he was pulseless
and mr floyd was pulseless at one point
and it really made no effort to take
care of the person
in their custody officer tao
watched most of the inter the
suffocation
and then only went over to keep people
from giving help
one person who is identified as a
medical
trained firefighter for the city of
minneapolis and that was dismissed
like were we going to believe her
so they kept trained medical people from
providing
help
these were all uniformed peace officers
adding to that abuse
of trust and authority
know i know the defense has asked the
court for probation
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
arguing that it's
so outside of the realm of i think real
possibility
this is a murder i understand some of
the arguments made on behalf of mr
chauvin
i understand well no i can't understand
what his family members and friends are
going through
i can't but it's certainly not enough
for a departure to probation for a
second-degree murder
we believe your honor that these four
aggravating factors
important findings that the court has
made
certainly justify an upward departure
because there are four of them not
standing alone but in a sense
not overlapping but coming together to
show
this is not the typical second-degree
murder this is egregious
and this justifies a double upward
departure
from the top of the box which is 180
months
we're asking the court to do a double
departure recognizing all four factors
to 360 months
as i mentioned before this is fencing
this is the time for victims
right this is the time for the loved
ones
the victim and the community to have a
say
again i i commend this family i
i commend all of the loved ones the
friends the people that have
been involved in this case for
tolerating and and being gracious
none of this of course can bring george
floyd back that's very true
but this is the time for a criminal
justice system to say we hear you
this is the time for their criminal
justice system to say we recognize
that this harm you're going through is
real and while we can't feel what you're
feeling
we know we can do what the your criminal
justice system should do
and recognize the severity of this crime
and reflect that in a sentence to be
given
it's time for this criminal justice
system to say we recognize
this is more serious than the typical
second degree
unintentional murder more reasons the
court found
reflect that and give this court more
than an adequate basis to do that
your honor we ask the court to impose a
sentence of 360 months
commitment to the commissioner of
corrections
you know your honor there are no fines
and murder cases
and we would ask the court uh just to
reserve the issue of restitution of
restitution
and clarify that with the family and
present that to the court
for 30 days thank you
thank you anything further from the
state all right
hey mr nelson
i'm sorry mr blackburn i'm sorry i just
thought
uh thank you your honor your honor at
this time the defendant's mother carolyn
pawlenty would like to address the court
if you could uh state your full name
spelling each of your names
and proceed when you're ready
carolyn c-a-r-o-l-y-n
pawlenty p-a-w l-e-n-t-y
i am the mother of derek shawn
i am here to speak on behalf of my
entire family
on november 25th 2020
not only did derek's life change forever
but so did mine and my families
derek devoted 19 years of his life
to the minneapolis police department
it has been difficult for me to hear and
read what the media
public and prosecution
team believed derek to be an aggressive
heartless and uncaring person
i can tell you that is far from the
truth
my son's identity has also been reduced
to that as of that as
a racist
wants his court to know that none of
these
things are true and that my son
is a good man
derek always dedicated his life
and time to the police department even
on his days off
he would call in to see if they needed
help
derek is a quiet thoughtful
honorable and self selfless man
he has a big heart and he always has put
others before his own
the public will never know the loving
and caring man he is that his family
does
even though i have not spoken publicly
i have always supported him 100 percent
and always will
derek has played over and over in his
head the events of that day
i've seen the toll it has taken on him
i believe a lengthy sentence will not
serve derek well
when you sentence my son
he will also be sentencing me
i will not be able to see
derek talk to him on the phone
or give him our special hug
the fact that when he is released
his father and i most likely will not be
here
my happiest moment is when i gave birth
to you
and my second is when
i was honored to pin your police badge
on you i remember you whispering to me
don't stick me with it
derek i want you to know i have always
believed in your innocence
and i will never waver from that
i have read numerous letters
from people around the world that also
believe in your innocence
no matter where you go where you are
i will always be there to visit you i
promise you
i will stay strong as we talked about
and i want you to do the same for me
i will do what you told me to do take
care of myself
so i will be here for you when you come
home
remember there is no stronger bond or
love than a mother's love
one final thought i want you to remember
remember you are my favorite son
thank you for your time
charleston
thank you very much your honor uh it is
my intent that my remarks this afternoon
be
quite brief i do not intend to
relitigate the facts of this case nor
spend any substantial time
looking at the law
the court is very familiar with the
facts of this case
and the parties have fully briefed the
court
relevant to the sentencing factors
and we recognize that in any case any
sentencing that comes before the court
the court is tasked with a difficult job
the court must craft a sentence that
serves the interests of justice
a rather nebulous term the court must
take into consideration
the victim impact public interests
as well as the circumstances and the
history of the defendant
and in this case more than any other
that likely any of us have ever been
involved in
that task is exceedingly more difficult
in my remarks today i just wish to
briefly address
each of those three considerations
starting with the public impact
as i believe we are all cognizant of
this case is at the epicenter of a
cultural and political divide
we tried to keep a lot of that out of
the courtroom during trial
and make this case about the facts
but we recognize what has happened
as a result of this case
there are a great number of people who
will view any sentence you pronounce
as overly lenient and insufficient to
satisfy
justice but there are an equal number of
people
who will view any sentence you pronounce
as draconian or overbearing
either way some percentage of the public
will view your sentence as a miscarriage
of justice
the intensity of the public interest in
this case cannot be understated
i trust that the volume and of
correspondence that each of us
has received from the public at large
is indicative of these very sentiments
on both sides
as i was informed just yesterday the
attorney general's office established a
website
some web submission to accept community
impact statements
again in my understanding is in a little
over two weeks they received
over a thousand submissions again
on both sides
by my very best estimate since my
representation of mr chauvin
began last summer i would estimate
that i have received over 5000 emails
over a thousand voicemails and hundreds
and hundreds of handwritten letters
again
from both sides and i expect that your
honor has
likewise been inundated with
public comment and scrutiny
the impact that this case has had on
this community is profound
it goes far beyond what happened on may
25th
of last year it has been at the
forefront
of our national consciousness and it has
weaved its way
into every nearly every facet of our
lives
from the entertainment that we consume
to the presidential politics
from protests to conspiracy theories
in the end it is my sincere hope that
when this proverbial dust fails
the community at the community impact
brings forth principled debate
and civil public discourse and
ultimately leaves
a public positive effect on the city of
minneapolis
the state of minnesota the united states
but nevertheless while this court may
consider the community impact
it is for these very same reasons that
the court must turn to the foundational
legal principles and remember that
justice is blind
law is built on reason and common sense
and it cannot be permitted to be
assailed by public
opinion
turn to the second consideration which
is the victim impact
the death of george white the death of
george
floyd was tragic
he is loved by his family members
he is loved by his friends
and his death is justifiably mourned
by those whose lives he impacted
he is a son a brother a father
an uncle and a friend of mine
and as the court heard today the impact
and the loss of his life
of the loss of his life simply just it
can't be simplified
and it will take time
finally your honor the court must take
into consideration
just like it has to take into
consideration the aggravating factors
it needs to take into consideration the
mitigating factors
and the mitigating factors that set
forth by the sentencing guidelines
really point to the trog analysis
essentially ultimately in this case
when i spend a lot of time again arguing
for a probationary sentence
that's brief
but that being said when we look at the
tribe factors
who is derek schroeder
derek shoven spent 19 years as a
minneapolis police officer
he loved being a police officer
i was contacted during the course of my
representation
and i've had numerous uh conversations
with his fellow police officers or
fellow police officers that worked with
derek some retired
some still active and they told me that
he was a solid police officer
that he did his job that if
somebody asked him to do a particular
task
he never complained he did it
one person told me that if one of his
sergeants told me that if i had
asked him to dig a ditch for eight hours
he would have picked up a shovel and he
would have never complained
for a second he would have done his job
he was decorated as a police officer
multiple life-saving awards
he was decorated for valor
he was proud to be a police officer
because what he liked
to do was help people and as
the statistics show the vast majority of
police work
is helping people
he was proud to be a minneapolis police
officer
he served his country as the united
states in the united states army
and he too is a son
a brother and a father
a friend he too
his life
the the life he's lived he's not coming
into this as a career criminal
with six points five points four points
he's coming into this never having
violated the law because he lived an
honorable
life and he attempted to live an
honorable life
derek children was not even scheduled to
work on may 25th
2020. volunteered because there was
short staffing at the time
i know from numerous conversations that
i've had with there
that his brain is littered with what ifs
what if i just had not agreed to go in
that day
what if things had gone differently what
if i never responded to that call
what if what if what if the truth of the
matter is and the end result is
that we are here after a jury verdict
finding him guilty of these offenses
and the court's consideration should not
only be focused on the aggravating
factors
but the mitigating factors as well
the minnesota sentencing guidelines
commission was established
for a reason and yes the court in
circumstances like these
has discretion to go beyond an
aggravated sentence beyond
the presumptive sentences established by
the sentencing guidelines
but the sentencing guidelines don't
differentiate between
second-degree murders someone robs a
liquor store
a police officer is involved in an
incident and
a person dies in police custody
the law presumes the legislature
presumes
that the sentencing guidelines as
established this is a
sufficient penalty for all
of the second-degree murder categories
or cases you would see
from 2019 back to 2010
a total of 90 people were sentenced
for second-degree murder
both sentences those people there were
more than not that
but people who had a zero criminal
history score
more than 90 people were sentenced
67 or 60 of those 90 people
received a guideline sentence of 150
months
so two-thirds of all people in this same
position
received a guideline sentence
20 percent received an aggravated
sentence
18 of the 90 and 12
or excuse me 13 or 12 individuals
were granted mitigated departures
so if the legislature and the intent of
the sentencing guidelines is to
eliminate sentencing disparity
the law should presume that the
guideline sentence
is what is appropriate in this case
judge may take
you may take into consideration at this
point those aggravating factors
but you have to counter balance them
which is the goal of the law
with the mitigating factors
i know that this has been an incredibly
difficult case for the floyd
family to have to endure
the state of minnesota
likewise prosecutors in this case have
endured quite a bit
as has mr shulman's family
this is a case that is change has
changed the world
to some degree and i hope it's positive
it's my hope that the court follows the
sentencing guidelines
applies the law in a reasoned
manner and imposes a justice
mr schulman would you join mr nelson at
the lectern
uh mr showman this is your opportunity
if you wish to
uh give any input to the court and so i
turn it over to you and your journey
thank you your honor
um at this time due to some
additional legal matters at hand i'm not
able to give a
full formal statement at this time um
but very briefly though i
do want to give my condolences to the
floyd family
um there's going to be some other
information
in the future that would be of interest
and
i hope things will give you some
some peace of mind thank you
and i'll note that i did read your
comments in the pre-sentence
investigation as well
all right we are going to take a
15-minute recess so that i can complete
the sentencing order based on what i've
heard today
and let's reconvene at 2 45. we're in
recess
all right thank you all we're back in
session and on the record
well first of all i wanted to thank
everybody for being here
and for providing the input you did not
just people who were in the courtroom
here but also those who provided written
statements
both from the floyd family
and the defendant's family i've read all
the impact statements that were
submitted earlier
and listen carefully to all the input
here today and it is truly appreciated
that you took the time to stay with this
case
and to provide me with input i
have reviewed the pre-sentence
investigation
and carefully considered all the facts
the case in the law
but my comments are actually going to be
very brief
because most of it's going to be in
writing
i have a 22-page memorandum that is
going to be attached to the sentencing
order
and why am i doing it in writing to
emphasize the fact that
determining the appropriate sentence in
any case
and in this case is a legal analysis
it's applying the rule of law to the
facts of an individual
and specific case and that is why as
opposed to trying to be
being profound here on the record i
prefer that you
read the legal analysis that explains
how i determine the sentence in this
case
what the case is or what the sentence is
not based on
is emotion or sympathy
but at the same time i want to
acknowledge the
deep and tremendous pain
that all the families are feeling
especially the floyd family
you have our sympathies and i
acknowledge
and hear the pain that you are feeling
i acknowledge the pain not only of those
in this courtroom
but the floyd family who are outside
this courtroom
and other members of the community it
has been painful
throughout hennepin county
throughout the state of minnesota and
even the country
but most importantly we need to
recognize the pain of the floyd family
i'm not going to attempt to be profound
or clever
because it's not the appropriate time
i'm not basing my sentence also on
public opinion
i am not basing it on any attempt to
send any messages
a trial court judge the job of a trial
court judge
is to apply the law to specific facts
and to deal with individual cases
and so
mr chauvin as to count one
based on the verdict of the jury finding
you guilty of unintentional
second-degree murder while committing a
felony under minnesota statute 609
.19 subdivision ii paran1
it is the judgment of the court that you
now stand convicted of that offense
pursuant to minnesota statutes section
60904
counts two and three will remain
unadjudicated as they are lesser
offenses
of count one
as sentence for count one the court
commits you to the custody of the
commissioner of corrections
for a period of 270 months that's 270
that is a 10-year addition to the
presumptive sentence
of 150 months
this is based on your
abuse of a position of trust and
authority and also the particular
cruelty shown to george floyd
you're granted credit for 199 days
already served pay the mandatory
surcharge of 78 dollars to be paid from
prison wages
you're prohibited from possessing
firearms ammunition
or explosives for the remainder of your
life provide a dna sample is required
register by law predatory offender as
required by law
and then you will receive a copy of the
order and also the attached memorandum
explaining the court's analysis
anything further from the all state if
this needs to be said we just ask that
it be executed forth with
lieutenant has remanded the custody of
the sheriff to be transported uh back to
the doc or
whichever custody he is currently
holding anything from defense
all right thank you we are adjourned
[Music]
here
how are you i miss you guys
oh
[Music]
yes
oh
[Music]
yes
we're gonna give him 22 and a half years
what we're waiting on
is attorney being trump
and things of that nature